a circular sanitary sewer is being
designed to have a minimum velocity of
2.5 ft per second at Peak flow the sewer
is made of cement mortar with a slope of
0.3% what is the minimum diameter in
inches required to meet the velocity
requirements for this
design so although the problem doesn't
come right out and say it we should be
able to determine that we need to use
Manning's equation for this problem
in Water Resources Manning's equation is
often used to find the flow in either a
partially full or full pipe if the pipe
is full and under Gravity flow
conditions this will be the peak flow
and velocity of the
pipe technically the peak flow may occur
slightly below the point where the pipe
is full but that's more of an in the
weeds conversation outside of the scope
of this problem anyway some of the hints
we can use to
determine that we need to use Mannings
include the following so one the
question provides the material of the
pipe which we can use to find the
Manning n value second the problem gives
us the velocity and slope of the pipe
both of which are terms in one of
Manning's forms finally we are asked to
find the diameter of the sewer and area
is also one of the terms within the
hydraulic radius so let's start by
solving the problem we are going to use
the form of Mannings that only includes
velocity so if we search Mannings in the
reference manual it should lead us to
page
345 that equation is going to be v =
1.48
6/ n time hydraulic radius raised to the
2/3 slope square
root so let's plug in our Givens below
we know that
velocity is
2.5 feet per
second 1.
1486 Over N now n we can look up in the
reference manual on the next page on
page
346 and for cement mortar we're going to
have an N value
of
0.013 next we can write out the expanded
term of hydraulic radius which is going
to be the area over the wetted
perimeter raised to the
2/3 finally slope square
root as you can see we need to expand
the hydraulic radius into its
constituent terms
so over here we can
do a over p
w to the
2/3
equals pi d^2 over
over Pi D so the area is still on the
top and the wed perimeter is still the
terms on the bottom
and all of that is still to the
2/3 simplifying this down we
get D over
4 to the
2/3 which we can finally simplify to
D to the
2/3 over
2.52 next we can plug that back into
Manning's equation
so step
four
2.5 feet per second equal 1.
1486 over
[Applause]
0.013 D to the
over
2.52 times the square root of the slope
and slope we talk about
but
0.3% can be written as
0.3 over 100
equals
0.003 so that's going to be over here
expressed as a
decimal and what we can do at this point
is solve for the diameter which is what
the problem asks for
so finally we can break this down to if
we
multiply these terms over here and then
divide by 1. 1486 and the
slope we will get D to the
23 equal
1.6t
and solving just for D we get
1.004 so that doesn't change much feet
which of course is just about 12
in and that is all it takes to solve
this problem in summary in this problem
we need to realize that we need Mannings
equation and we need to know where to
get our Mannings n
from we also need to remember that slope
should be expressed as a decimal even if
it is given as a percent and that's it